Joseph Epstein and author and editor
taught English and writing at
Northwestern University for more than 30
years in 2003 mr. Epstein was awarded a
National Humanities medal by the
National Endowment for the Humanities
and in 2004 he won the Harold u Rebelo
prize for his collection of short
stories fabulous small Jews he has been
a senior editor of Encyclopedia
Brittanica and editor of the American
scholar the quarterly Journal of Phi
Beta Kappa a frequent contributor to the
Weekly Standard National Review
commentary and the Wall Street Journal
he is the author of 27 books the most
recent of which is when spirits are
sorry wind sprints shorter essays his
fourth collection of short stories
frozen and time will be published this
spring please welcome me and introducing
mr. Epstein
how pleasing to be introduced by an
elegant young woman who made absolutely
no factual errors very grateful it's
very nice I'm delighted to be a
Hillsdale as you'll see my talk today is
not x-rated I assure you but in it I'm
going to say some things that I think I
couldn't say comfortably at Harvard Yale
Princeton and other designer schools as
I think of them and I'm grateful to
Hillsdale for allowing me to talk about
what I think are essential things in a
straightforward way and not every
college as we know in the country allows
one to do that anymore and it's a very
big deal and a good thing I'm grateful
before I began I do want to say that I'm
reminded whenever I give a talk that the
men and Gershom Scholem
the who was a great student of Jewish
mysticism in the Middle Ages once said
that whenever he gave a talk or a
lecture he always assumed to induce
humility in himself that there was
someone in the audience who knew as much
or more about the subject than he now I
thought about that and I'd like to ask
that person to please leave now so I can
get going without too much nervousness
well my title given to me by by the
conference directors is why do we read
biographies when I come upon an artist a
philosopher scientist a statesman an
athlete I admire I find myself
interested in his or her background
which is to say in their biography in
the hope of discovering what in their
past made possible our future eminence I
find it more than a touch difficult to
understand anyone so in curious as to
not have a similar interest
I have myself written scores of
biographical essays but never a
full-blown biography I once took a
publisher's advance to write the
biography of the American novelist John
Dos Passos a figure now slowly slipping
into the vast limbo inhabited by the
once famous but now nearly forgotten I
was 32 years old John Dos Passos was
then 73 and we died a year later after I
had signed my publishers contract
I wrote to informed him to inform him
that I hope to ride his life and sent
him some samples of my own published
writing he wrote back to say that he
would be pleased to help me in any way
he could though he would prefer I put my
liberal politics in mothballs and
promise never again to use the word
explicate three great facts or so I
thought dominated John Dos Passos his
life the first is that he was born a
bastard but an interesting twist here an
upper-class bastard the son of a man who
was a successful American lawyer and of
a mother who was a Virginian of high
social standing he John Dos Passos went
to choked under the name of John Madison
and thence to Harvard the second fact is
that he wrote a if not the great
American novel USA by title a work using
modernist techniques to explore the
pressures that society puts on men and
women of all social classes it is a book
that when I first read it at the age of
19 greatly moved me the third fact is
that those Passos underwent a strong
political conversion from a man who in
1932 voted for William G Foster the
Communist Party candidate for president
- a man of deeply conservative
principles and views the work of the
Stalinists and Spanish Civil War
prepared to kill the innocent to gain
their ends not only
Dos Passos as politics forever returned
such old friends as earnest Hemmingway
against him
a splendid biography of John Dos Passos
in other words was there to be written
but alas I never wrote it life in the
form of demands too elaborate and dull
to go into here intervened and I was
forced to that most odious act known to
the professional writer having to return
my publishers advance others have since
written biographies of John Dos Passos
but none to my mind altogether
successfully those processes famous
perhaps now too far faded for anyone of
high literary power to take on the task
of writing a first-class biography of
him not that let me add at 32 I was
myself likely to be up to the job I have
come to believe that at the heart of any
fully realized literary work a part
perhaps some satire and parody and
lyrical poetry is honouring the
complexity of the subject and in the
case of John Dos Passos I am fairly
certain that I could not have done so at
that relatively early age
a successful biography is at a minimum
one that conveys what the world thinks
of its subject what his closest family
and friends think of him and finally
crucially and sometimes most difficult
to obtain what he thinks of himself I
recently read - excellent biographies of
Cicero won by the German classicist
Manfred Froman and the other by the 19th
century French classicist
Gaston moi CA and what makes both
biographies especially good is the large
cache of 900 or so of Cicero's letters
that have survived along with another
hundred or so letters from his
correspondence these letters reveal
Cicero in all the pride hope
disappointment vanity and grandeur of a
man playing Roman politics at the very
highest level more and more than two
millennia ago Cicero's letters
marshalled in the pertinent order by
brilliant biographers bring him to life
in a far more intimate way than any
other figure in classical antiquity I
read these biographies of Cicero along
with some among his various voluminous
writings because Cicero is one of the
hundred or so key figures in Western
history and my ignorance of the details
of his life is one of the thousands of
gaps in my own knowledge of that history
I read them because one of the pleasures
of biography is reading about men and
women who played the game of life for
hire and more dramatic stakes than one
has oneself or is ever likely to do I
read them also because they revealed
Cicero to be perhaps the first example
of the intellectual in politics he is
the political and intellectual par
excellence a subject of long fascination
to be an intellectual not in politics
Cicero was a human-type of the highest
interest the man riven by the division
between his ideals and his personal
ambition he felt himself drawn to the
Roman aristocracy yet put off by its
insolence felt a natural conflict
between the temperament of the man of
letters and the politician for he wasn't
himself both it was alternately
fascinated and disgusted by politics
regularly retreating from them to his
library at his villa in Tusculum then
drawn back to the fray at Rome he was a
man who knew disappointment and a
mistake in marriage and tragedy and the
loss of a beloved daughter when she was
30 he left a bib ulis son in whom his
family law and petered out attempting
always to avoid extremes longing for
return to the glories of the Roman
Republic about which he may have been
guilty of fantasizing Cicero ended up
being killed by Marcus Antonius men man
of Marcus Antonius who nailed his
severed head and the hands that wrote
the attacks upon antonio's up in the
forum for all to see in Gaston Basha is
brilliant biographies
and his friends one has offered dazzling
portraits of such figures as the
financier pomponius Atticus of who moi
CA writes he was the most adroit man of
that time but we know that there are
other forms of praise that are of
greater value than this of Cicero's
protege Marcus Cayley is Rufus washi air
rights lows cautious and clear-eyed
persons were entirely taken up with the
fear of being duped and who always see
the faults of others so plainly are
never anything but lukewarm friends and
useless analyze ba ca discovers
describes Cicero's brother Quintus
playing quote the ungrateful and
difficult part of a younger brother of a
great man it provides portraits of
leading female figures of the day
including Claudia the lesbian of
catalases love poems of whom it was said
quote she danced better than it was
proper for an honest woman to do these
observations are capped off by the
remark of Cato that quote the day that
they women become your equals
they will be here superiors I hope you
find some of these remarks about
Cicero's friends and contemporaries as
interesting as I do
if you do I trust the reason is that you
share my interest in human character and
then that still probably perpetually
mysterious force behind it human nature
the proper study of mankind as Alexander
Pope had it is man if there is a more
interesting subject than human character
I do not know it
part of its interest derives from its
bottomless its inexhaustible variety
what one person does what does one
person despite all the disadvantages
dealt him by the lottery of birth
survived I'm sad why does one person
despite all the disadvantages dealt him
by the lottery of birth survive surmount
and go on to achieve greatness
while another with every advantage
allotted to him stumbles
goes down biography is the most
promising place to seek the answers some
people read biography to compare the
subjects life with their own in the Kent
term of our day they identify one
wonders though if this isn't a crude way
of reading biography I read Peter greens
biography of Alexander the Great
I promise you without once thinking of
weeping because I had no more world's to
conquer
nor did I identify when I read EF
Benson's the life of Alcibiades instead
I marveled at the high jinks of a man
who may have been the world's greatest
seducer and con artist I should have to
be a fan test of the first water to
imagine myself as in any way even
comparable to such men identifying with
historical figures is reminiscent to
Volodymyr Nabokov for marking on the
coarseness of identifying with figures
in fiction the best readers in the book
I felt identified with the artist by
this I take it he meant that when a
character in fiction gets in a tight
spot don't worry about that character
worry instead about how the artist will
get him out of it one ought to read
biographies in roughly the same spirit
with a certain sophisticated detachment
if worrying than expending that worry
not on the life of the subject but on
the skill of the chronicler the
biographer whose task it is to take the
measure of the person he is writing
about with reasonable exactitude and
penetrating judgment all going to form a
persuasive
portrait many years ago I read through
the five volumes of Lyon Adele's
biography of Henry James I cannot say
that I identified with James a man
infinitely more subtle than I but I did
I like to think take a few lessons from
Henry James James some of you will
recall wrote a story called the lesson
of the master in which a famous novelist
advises a young writer not to marry
because it will impede his art when the
for the famous novelist dies he turns
round and marries the woman the young
writer loves might the lesson here be
that the best advice is not to take
advice at least in matters of the heart
Adele's biography provides the best
account I know of the quotidian life of
the professional writer
the biographer recounts James dealings
with editors and publishers his hopes
for popularity and commercial success I
can stand lots of gold James once
remarked the little enough of it came
his way through his writing above all
his loneliness and the almost certain
loneliness of anyone who chooses as
James did the spec tutorial as opposed
to the act of life Henry James was both
fascinated and repelled by a biography
he himself wrote a biography of the
American sculptor William Wetmore story
the biographical question plays out many
of James's own stories and in none more
than in the story called the figure in
the carpet the narrator of that story
some of you will remember seeks to
discover the animating force behind the
work of an older novelist he admires
named you Vera Kerr America allows that
there is such a force it's the very
string that my pearls are strung on he
tells the narrator but he isn't about to
reveal what it is another literary
critic and biographer a man named George
korvac claims after a long effort to
have discovered it this repeated theme
that turns up ever so subtly in veracruz
work and that it is quote something like
the figure in the Persian carpet before
revealing it in the book he is writing
Corbett dies in a carriage accident he
was revealed a great secret to his wife
but she too was not telling Vera Kerr
himself dies and the great underlying
force propelling his work is never
discovered which one senses is just fine
with Henry James the metaphor of the
figure in the carpet is I think
wonderfully suggestive causing us to
look at our own lives to discover
if there is some repeated pattern or
theme that has guided our destiny made
us succeed or fail brought us
contentment or pitched us into
depression Galen Strawson the English
philosopher in a chapter in a recent
book called life writing thinks
otherwise holding that life is what we
make of it
freefall essentially patternless leaving
us all in the condition not of Persian
but of shag rugs is this so if it is
does this not leave us little more than
mere bugs in the rugs of a vast design
but crying behind all personal fathoming
about Henry James's strange story one
thing is clear James sides not with his
narrator but with his invented novelist
you very Kerr in another more nut widely
known story the aspirin papers James
writes with contempt about the prying
biographer ready to do anything to
acquire the letters of a long-dead
famous poet by some thought to be Lord
Byron from his now elderly lover sexual
want of scrupulous scrupulosity and the
part of the biographer such as the want
of scrupulosity and the part of the
biographer that James has one of the
other characters in the story call him a
publishing scoundrel late in life
Henry James burned a vast quantity of
his letters an act meant to discourage
any possible biographer of his own life
an empty gesture as it turned out for so
charming were James letters that
everyone else saved those he sent to
them with the consequence that the
University of Nebraska Press which is
publishing all of James's extent letters
is this year bringing out its tenth
volume and this volume goes only tonight
1880 James lived on to 1916 Leon Adele
who much admired Henry James as his
biographer nonetheless could not resist
Freud knives in
Adela's rather orthodox Freudianism mars
but does not destroy his five-volume
work it does not lock James into an
Oedipus complex Greek myths covering
private parts was volodymyr in the
volkoff's characterization the Freud's
thought but he does make great head hey
out of what he takes to be the sibling
rivalry between Henry James and his
equally brilliant if uh Turley different
brother William even hinting at
homoerotic feeling for William of the
part of Henry was the rivalry truly
there my own view is that the two
brothers were so different in their
mental make up the intellectual note
sounding most strikingly and William the
aesthetic and Henry that rivalry really
wasn't an issue they competed so to say
at different games philosophy for
William literature for Henry comparing
the two is rather like asking who is the
better athlete Michael Jordan or Roger
Federer Leon Adele does show remarkable
strength restraint for Freudian that is
and not prying into Henry James's sex
life so far as this is known Henry James
never had physical relations with anyone
male or female anticipating those later
biographers and critics who would write
in a less decorous time Adele
considering the possibility that James
was homosexual noted that there is no
firm evidence to suggest that Tenri
James ever engaged in acts of
homosexuality and lets it go at that
biographers who came after Leon Adele
allows have not for some among them
James's homosexuality is presumed his
active pursuit of his true sexual nature
is assumed have been restrained only by
his timidity the RFT's of the biographer
James wrote that devilish art is somehow
practically thinning it simplifies while
seeking to enrich the master a
biographical novel by the Irish writer :
Tobin himself something of a
homosexual portrays homosexuality as as
at the center of James's life and has
him oddly handsome male servants the
problem here is not just a case of
mistaken identification but the effect
this figures to have on skewering the
interpretation of Henry James's novels
and stories in a homosexual direction
Henry James were he alive would I dare
say have been appalled biography is of
course subject to other skew rings in
our time the political not least among
them the politics of the biographer if
he allows them into his work and have
fatal effect I first noted this some
years ago in Andrew Motion's biography
of the poet Philip Larkin humorously
picking his way through felt Larkin
Kingsley Amos correspondence and other
of Larkins letters motion with a great
display of self virtue convicts Larkin
of misogyny racism and other standard
charges leveled in the court of
political correctness this has since
been set a right by a recent biography
of Larkin by a man named James Booth who
has shown Philip Larkin to be a man more
than decent in his relations with women
the people who work for him at the whole
university library and everyone else who
ever encountered him years before this
something similar with l HL Mencken who
was also brought in by the political
correctness police anta anti-defamation
league division in Mankins case to the
usual complaints of racism and sexism
anti-semitism was added these charges
too turned out to be unjust Menken such
was the largeness of his heart married a
woman knowing she was dying he did so
principally to bring comfort to her
Menken's best friends were in fact jews
dim-witted biographers sydney seemed
unable to decipher the differences as in
the case of Larkin and Menken both
between comically expressed reactionary
opinions and lives marked by gracious
action
a flagrant case of ruining a politics
ruining biography is that of a Stanford
professor named Arnold Ramprasad in his
biography of the novelist Ralph Ellison
I came I should tell you to the
Ramprasad biography published in 2007
with a special interest hoping he might
solve a minor but genuine interest for
me many years ago Ralph Ellison invited
me to join him for lunch at the Century
Club in New York I met him there on a
sunny winter's afternoon a at noon and
departed in the dusk at 4:30 p.m. with
the same happy glow as a boy I departed
double feature movie matinees we talked
about serious things gossiped told each
other jokes laughed a great deal I
enjoyed myself hugely believed Ellison
did too and too part of the Century Club
confident I had made a new friend of a
writer I much admired soon afterwards I
wrote to Ralph as he now was to me to
thank him for the luncheon in an
immensely enjoyable afternoon no answer
a week or so later I wrote to him again
inviting him to write for the American
scholar which I was then editor no
answer after an interval of another
three or four weeks
I wrote yet again to inquire if he had
received at my earlier letters nothing
puzzled I wrote to him no more had i so
proceeded misperceived
what I fought the reciprocal pleasure of
that lunch at the Century Club on that
winter's afternoon a few years after
this I had a letter from the reader of
mine asking if I knew Ralph Ellison he
went on to say that he and his wife had
met Ellison and his wife at the Newport
Jazz Festival and the four of them spent
the most pleasing weekend together
afterwards though Ellison had answered
none of his letters what he wondered as
I had early wondered might have gone
wrong
on the strangeness of Ralph Ellison's
behavior in these instances professor
rompers said his biographer sheds no
light instead much of his attention is
taken up by finding Ralph Ellison
nowhere near so virtuous a man as he
Arnold Ram percent apparently is
represents charge against Ralph Ellison
adding on to his being a bad brother and
a poor husband is that it ran person's
words Ellison's life is a cautionary
tale to be told against the dangers of
elitism and alienation especially
alienation from other blacks what Ralph
Ellison turns out to have been guilty of
is not having so to say got on the bus
he was and remained an integrationist
and fought the Black Power movement of
grave mistake he insisted on the
complexity of black experience in
America and refused absolutely to play
the victim hood game refraining from the
rhetoric of public rage and demagoguery
he was an artist before he was a
politician and in the realm of art was
an unapologetic elitist believing in
pursuing the best in Western culture and
african-american folk culture to the
exclusion of all else he did not line up
to praise young black writers simply
because they were black art he held who
was colorblind nor did he praise
established black writers James Baldwin
Toni Morrison if he did not think them
truly praiseworthy rappers are charge
has finally come down to what he takes
to be Ralph Ellison's pernicious
opinions and we way he knows they are
pernicious is that they do not comport
with his own biographers opinions left
to speculate by the way upon what was
behind Ralph Ellison's odd behavior
toward me and I gather others he had
charmed I have concluded that Ellison
was a gracious and gregarious man who
later came to regret his own natural
sociability in 1951-52 at the age of 39
he wrote invisible
man a novel that won all the prizes and
worthy acclaim of its day although he
lived another 42 years and produced two
collections of essays Ralph Ellison
never wrote a second novel how this must
have worn on him psychologically one
cannot hope fully to know he would go
out into the world his natural charm
easily met him friends and afterwards
returned to his desk the scene of
decades-long defeat determined not to
waste further time on these newly made
friends or so I have conjectured in his
biography of Ralph Ellison professor
romper said not merely wrongly degraded
a good man but in his biographies
pretends to definitiveness the work runs
to 672 pages the book is likely to scare
away other Ellison biographers for
decades which is a sadness in an
injustice to be definitive has
increasingly become the goal for
contemporary biographers a definitive
biography by current standards leaves
nothing out straightaway one sees the
impossibility of the goal unless one
does a day by day hour by hour minute by
minute account of a life definitiveness
defined as utter thoroughness cannot be
realized the greatest biography ever
written
James Boswell's life of Johnson which I
have reread over the past year is not
definitive for one thing the book
largely shirks Samuel Johnson's early
life and concentrates on the 21 years
during which Boswell knew Johnson
roughly from 1763 to 1784 beginning when
he was 22 and Johnson fifty-four nor has
any biographer ever intruded himself in
a biography so completely as Boswell did
in his book about Johnson so much is
this the case that some have claimed
that the life of Johnson is true for the
price of one here both a biography and
an autobiography
the making of the life of Johnson is of
course Boswell's emphasis on Samuel
Johnson's habits his inflexible dignity
of character his ponderous physical
presence above all his brilliant
conversation into which Boswell often
off all but noted him Samuel Johnson was
an extraordinary writer the essays from
the Rambler are among the finest we have
as a biographer his the life of Richard
savage and lives the poet hold up
splendidly in the vanity of human wishes
he composed a poem that still lives his
dictionary is one of the most impressive
one-man intellectual performances of all
time along with Matthew Arnold and TS
Eliot Samuel Johnson is one of the three
indispensable literary critics in all of
English literature yet it took James
Boswell in a biography to bring him to
life Boswell held that in his biography
Johnson quote will be seen as it really
was for I profess to write neither pan
Gyrich with will must be all praise but
his life which great and good as he was
must not be supposed to be entirely
perfect Boswell claimed that in his book
Johnson was seen quote more completely
than any man who has ever lived
and he made good I believe on the claim
with all his gruffness his blunderbuss
conversation in which he often talked
for victory his intellectual bullying
his act of extraordinary Christian
charity his acts of extraordinary
Christian charity Samuel Johnson emerges
in Boswell's life flaws and all as a
moral hero without Boswell Johnson would
perhaps not have found his prominent
place in the pantheon of English
literature no biographer has ever
rendered his subject a greater service
than James Boggs well did for Samuel
Johnson a tendency of biographies under
the tyranny of definitive has been for
them to grow longer and longer this may
have begun with mark shores 869 page
biography
of Sinclair Lewis published in 1961 a
recent biography of Bob Hope runs to 565
pages the first volume of Gary Giddins
biography of Bing Crosby to 768 pages
first volume James Kaplan's recent
biography of Frank Sinatra - 992 pages J
Michael Lennon's biography of Norman
Mailer to 960 pages and the first volume
was a career leaders biography of Saul
Bellow - 812 pages why are these
biographies so lengthy they are so I
think because of their authors mistaken
ambition for biographical definitiveness
they not only want every word redeemable
about but the last word upon their
respective subjects along with being
longer contemporary biographers are less
interested in moral heroism such as
Samuel Johnson's or simple greatness
such as that of Alexander the Great
Thomas Edison Abraham Lincoln of the
kind that aroused the interest of early
readers modern biographers labor in
search of secrets often ones linked to
sexual behavior
owing to Lincoln's stretch his
biographical essays in eminent
Victorians a book of 1918 modern
biographers are frequently as frequently
eager to demean as to exalt their
subjects Strachey undertook to take the
deflate the Victorians who were such
figures among them as John Stuart Mill
Charles Darwin Benjamin Disraeli and
George Eliot constitute perhaps the
greatest intellectual efflorescence
efflorescence of any period in history
the book made great waves at the time of
its appearance and had a strong if not
necessarily salubrious influence in
changing the nature of biographical
writing toward the iconoclastic perhaps
the best Vantage for a biographer is to
admire his subject without being sherri
of recounting his weaknesses a model of
such a book in my own recent reading is
the Russian born honorary Troy yachts
jordania try ott who also wrote
biographies of Tolstoy Pushkin and
Chekhov brought his trade anyof in at a
mere 162 pages the biography conveys the
literary artists life and character an
elusive and thoroughly illuminating way
when one has come to its end one feels
that one knows Ivan Turgenev well and as
a clearer view of his novels than
formerly if anything is left out one
feels it cannot have been essential the
history of the world wrote Thomas
Carlyle is but the biography of great
men not everyone you should know what
agree sir Ronald Syme who wrote
impressive biographies of solace and
Tacitus is among those who would not at
its worst wrote Simon is the Roman
Revolution biography is flat and
schematic at its best
it is often baffled by the hidden dis
cords of human nature
moreover undue emphasis upon the
character of a single person invests
history with dramatic unity at the
expense of truth biography and history
are of course not the same and yet
biography is what many among us find
most enticing in history as when Tacitus
writes about Papa Nero second wife that
she quote possessed every womanly asset
except goodness to her married or
bachelor bedfellows were alike
she was indifferent to a reputation
insensitive to men's love and unloving
herself advantage dictated to bestow
love her favors or as when Edward Gibbon
writes of the Emperor Gordy and the
younger twenty-two concubines in a
library of sixty-two thousand volumes
attested the variety of his inclinations
and from the productions which he left
behind him it appears the latter as well
as the former were designed for use
rather than ostentation yes it takes a
moment to get that Devonian sentence
fully
let it wave over you Ronald Siam himself
enlivens this history of the roman
revolution with dab biographical touches
as when of a secondary figure named el
Manette meant monotonous plank as he
writes a nice calculation of his own
interests and in this situation safety
carried him through well time
treacheries to a peaceful old age in the
end biography is one of the best
safeguards against conceptualize in
history create a concept Ortega wrote
and reality leaves the room and of the
belief as well that human beings are
invariably defeated by the overwhelming
forces of history biography counters
determinism the notion of history being
made chiefly or even exclusively by
irresistible tendencies trends and
movements it reinforces the idea that
fortune accident above all strong
character can rise above the impersonal
forces of politics economics and even
culture to form human destiny and change
the flow of history itself for this
reason and many more I say long live
biography thank you very much
if that person who knows a lot more than
I do rule ask me questions I'll do the
best I can thank you thank you thank you
for that that's the first thing I'm
going to do in the next life once I
answer one day el Vettes
yes it's going to be a real detriment I
think I think there's no question about
that
I mean the only the only hope they'll
have is that the FBI after they get
through with mrs. Clinton I loved your
sharing with us about Ralph Ellison and
because it illustrates for me the
importance of us being careful how we
how we interpret our experiences and our
understanding of the subject for example
as I heard your story my immediately
thought and I wrote it down here is that
he may have been a man who lived in the
presence and left your encounter in the
past maybe he never read his mail and
maybe he did not want to respond because
he didn't want to take advantage of your
friendship for his own publishing
advance so all that to say I interpreted
it very charitably which brings me to my
question which is you warned us about
the dangers of bringing our politics
into interpreting someone's writing but
is there a danger in bringing for the
biography to be too charitable to his
subjects and what can you suggest to
help us in that area well I'd say it had
been too terrible is the right side to
err on I suppose I remember some years
ago a man gosh I can't remember his name
no but he wrote a 700
biography of Page biography of Stephen
Crane proving that Stephen Crane was
worthless not not sinking tasks where
does that leave him so I think one does
if one is going to write a biography I
think one probably does best to start
with some base of admiration and expend
charity where one can at the hope of
course is a perfect balance at which I
think John in some ways Boswell achieves
with Johnson
you know he'll talk about Johnson's you
know it's really intellectually beating
up other people in conversation and and
so forth and there's a marvelous essay
on this subject by max Beerbohm called a
clergyman in some little scene in the
midst of 1,400 page life of Johnson
there are people around and Johnson is
holding forth and someone a clergy in
Basel writes clergymen said what about
materialism and Basel said it's have no
available and max Beerbohm wrote what
happened to that clergyman did he go I
didn't go home to feed it out early
so but Boswell talks about the bullying
of John snowless but he also talks about
these extraordinary Christian charity
and sweetness of the man and somehow
it's to get that balance must be the
great trick yes
ah that's that's a fine point fact I
wrote I wrote a book called fabulous
book of stories and I gave it the title
fabulous small Jews which I've had all
sorts of reactions that title I want
this book for my husband he's a fabulous
large Italian and well you know it comes
from a poem the tiny phrase does by carl
shapiro called basil it's called
hospital and the quatrain goes this
oxford of Cygnet of sicknesses kick
kings of laying hair and fabulous small
jews and actresses whose legs were
always news and some of that phrase
fabulous sons many of the characters in
my story were I'd say the first thing be
a fabulous small to is you must be under
six foot eight beyond that I'm not
prepared to go but thank you for an
amusing question good well thank you for
being so attentive to me I'm grateful to
them and I really do mean when I said
about Hillsdale so many of the things I
said in this piece about about Ralph
Ellison and and about Henry James and
homosexuality I think could not easily
be said in a lot of other places without
people just being tick to the Max's that
kids used to say thank you again